eric sinclair politologue bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors on vient de le dire la
proposition de dissoudre le ccf quels
sont les faits dont le collectif s'est
rendu responsable et qui ont poussé
l'auteur des faits à passer à l'acte en
réalité on peut pas faire un lien direct
et d'ailleurs je pense que le ministre
ne le fait pas un lien direct entre eux
l'action globale du ccf qui vise à
disqualifier tout propos opposant une
fin de recevoir aux islamistes à toutes
leurs revendications dans la société et
la volonté de tuer de certains en
revanche le ccf est une organisme qui
promeut une idéologie islamiste c'est à
dire qui promeut la volonté de voir
l'islam sous toutes ses formes
religieuses bien évidemment mais ça
c'est garanti par les libertés
fondamentales en france mais aussi
culturel est également politique se
développer librement dans la société
française et disqualifie tous ses
opposants et en faisant ça ils créé un
terreau qui est favorable finalement à
la halle actions d'aidé radicaliser
parce qu'ils se sentent soutenus
institutionnellement par un organisme
qui quelque part présentent comme étant
l'ennemi tout ce qui s'oppose de façon
générale à l'islam et c'est là qu'on
commence à a touché les sujets
compliqués c'est à dire que quand on
parle d'islam
il faut toujours précisé est ce qu'on
parle de la religion est ce qu'on parle
de la politique hausse qu'on parle de la
civilisation et comme le ccf englobe
dans le terme islamophobie toutes
critiques y compris de l'islamisme y
compris de l'islam civilisationnel
il semble finalement dire aux musulmans
attention vous êtes attaqué la
république ne vous aime pas l'état et
islamophobe et il va chercher à vous
nuire et en disant ça il favorise
finalement les actions haineuses dudu 2
d'un certain nombre de détraqués d'un
certain nombre d'islamiser d'un certain
nombre de
radicaliser de terroristes en puissance
mais disons quand même que la
dissolution du ccf ne peut pas être la
solution la réponse du gouvernement à la
tacc contre samuel pâtit dire qu'on ne
peut pas imaginer que en ayant 10 ou le
ccf on ai répondu de façon absolue et et
finale au drame que nous venons de
connaître il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin
justement à quel moment selon vous le
gouvernement a failli dans cette fête
contre le terrorisme quel moment il
faillit non la question c'est à quel
moment il n'a pas failli il n'y a rien
qui se passe depuis 30 ans dans ce pays
donc la vraie question c'est quand est
ce que réellement va se mettre à faire
quelque chose donc il ya entre 400 et
500 mille étrangers qui rentre dans
notre pays sous différentes formes
emmanuel macron en 2019 ses 259 mille
visas c'est le site du ministère de
l'intérieur et qui précise sa de 259
mille visages de primo arrivants on ne
compte même pas et là dedans et les
mineurs isolés on compte pas le droit
d'asile en compte pas bien évidemment
toute l'immigration illégale et dont on
n'est pas informé que c'est donc il ya
chaque année une immigration massive qui
vient de tout un tas de pays de la
planète et qui nous empêche finalement
de savoir qui rentre dans ce pays et
avec quelles intentions parce que quand
on a un flux aussi massif d'individus
qui viennent sur le territoire français
est bien évidemment on a un tchétchène
qui rentre et qui tue samuel pâtit mais
on a aussi un impact cette année
soutenue par une partie de son village
qui vient lui aussi massacrée dans nos
rues et puis tout un tas d'autres
aujourd'hui qu'on ne connaît pas et qui
sont prêts à passer à la sans compter
les 2500 qui sont libérés entre 2018 et
2022 et qui sont déjà connus pour
radicalisation pour des faits de
terrorisme ou pour des associations de
malfaiteurs donc fondamentalement on a
une idéologie libérale qui est porté par
ce gouvernement depuis trois ans et qui
empêche toute action tant qu'on ne sait
pas quel type de population où on peut
on doit à surveiller de façon étroite
c'est un petit peu comme si vous aviez
dans dans un magasin des clients qui
rentrent et qui sortent constamment
à partir du moment où il n'y a pas de
danger ça ne pose aucun problème à
partir du moment où il ya un danger il
faut freiner les entrées et les sorties
pour savoir exactement qui on est à
l'intérieur on ne sait pas qui on a à
l'intérieur du territoire les services
de renseignement sont surchargés donc
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire que le
gouvernement est en passe de faire
quelque chose le président a acté un
début de réponse donnant lui acte de ce
qu'il a dit et puis maintenant il va
falloir passer la surmultipliée pour en
un mot pour terminer la vraie question
c'est l'état de droit
aujourd'hui l'état de droit est
extrêmement protecteur des libertés
individuelles
il n'est même pas certain que le
ministre de l'intérieur parviennent à
dissoudre le ccf fabrique saint quay
remercie d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes politologue